in Deutschland abgehängt warum wächst
die Wirtschaft nicht an damit einen
schönen guten Abend liebe Zuschauer in
allen Industrieländern geht es voran nur
Deutschland wächst nicht mehr woher das
grüne Wirtschaftswunder kommen soll dass
der Kanzler verspricht das fragen sich
nicht nur Unternehmerinnen und
Unternehmer drei von ihnen haben wir
heute eingeladen alle machen
praktischerweise auch Politik und darum
interessiert uns doppelt was sie auf die
Frage antworten warum wächst die
deutsche Wirtschaft nicht wir müssen
reden mit diesen Gästen
die stellvertretende
SPD-Fraktionsvorsitzende Verena Huberts
Klaus Ruhe Matzen CDU
Wirtschaftsminister von
Schleswig-Holstein
die Unternehmerin Marie Christine
Ostermann
und die beiden
Wirtschaftswissenschaftler Veronika
Grimm und Marcel Fratzscher
sie sind zu Gast bei Maybrit Illner und
die begrüßt alle gestern noch mal
ausgesprochen herzlich die Zahlen sind
schlecht liebe Zuschauer und die
Regierung ist zufrieden
wir haben eine Situation in der das
Wachstum nicht so stark ist wie wir uns
das wünschen so sind sie die Storchen
Hanseaten Rider
es hagelt Kritik für EZB OECD JMF ist
Deutschland Sorgenkind Wachstumsbremse
Stagnation noch hinter Island und
Großbritannien aber der Kanzler findet
wir haben eine sehr erfolgreiche
Leistungsbilanz im letzten und diesem
Jahr
schade und verflixt noch mal dass das
nicht durchdringt der
ifo-Geschäftsklimaindex stürzt den
dritten Monat in Folge ab
[Musik]
als das einzige Industrieland auf der
Welt befindet sich Deutschland im Jahr
2023 in der Rezession
und die Ampel verpackt altbekanntes zu
einem ganz neuen 10 Punkteplan da kannst
mit der Wirtschaft gefühlt nur noch
aufwärts gehen
Verena Huberts ist bei uns
stellvertretende Fraktionsvorsitzende
der SPD sie sind und waren selber
Gründerin und verraten uns mal als
erstes auf eigentlich die
Unternehmerinnen und Unternehmer auf die
sie so treffen ob die genauso begeistert
sind wie Olaf Scholz von der Arbeit der
Ampel natürlich sind gerade alle
angespannt und wir müssen ja auch
erstmal sehen wo wir herkommen wir
hätten ja in einer ganz anderen Krise
auch sein können und auch nächstes Jahr
sollen wir auch wieder wachsen aber
natürlich können wir uns gerade nicht
zufrieden geben denn wir müssen auch mal
an die strukturellen Probleme unseres
Landes ran die uns nämlich auch in
diesen Verschleiß von Infrastruktur
Investitionsrückstau aber vor allen
Dingen auch Investitionsklima gebracht
haben und deswegen gibt es einiges zu
tun deswegen habe ich kandidiert und
mitzumachen und nicht nur von außen zu
meckern wenn Stefan weil sich zu Wort
meldet und sagt die Rückmeldungen aus
der Wirtschaft sind allesamt negativ wir
sind zu langsam zu teuer zu schwer
fällig schließen sie sich dem
Ministerpräsidenten an nicht alle
negativ aber viele und deswegen müssen
wir auch schneller werden denn wir haben
gucken uns immer sehr gut in Bürokratie
in Regeln in Gesetzen aufgetürmt und da
mussten wir jetzt wirklich auch mal
abbauen damit wir nicht sechs Jahre für
einen Windrad brauchen sondern sechs
Monate und das ist nur eine Maßnahme die
es gilt anzupacken es gibt viel
anzupacken wir sind dankbar auch zwei
Wirtschaftswissenschaftler bei uns in
der Sendung heute zu haben Veronika
Grimm Ökonomen und Wirtschaftsweisen der
britische Economist titelte kürzlich mit
der Frage ob Deutschland wieder der
kranke Mann Europas wird wird er das
ja ich glaube es gibt eine gewisse
Gefahr dass wir jetzt aus dieser Krise
nicht so dynamisch rauskommen wie wir
uns das gewünscht haben wir haben zwei
Krisen erlebt wir sind sehr stark
getroffen worden durch die Energiekrise
weil wir sehr gasabhängig sind durch die
corona-krise weil die Lieferketten sehr
stark gelitten haben und jetzt gilt es
aus dem krisenmodus rauszukommen die
strukturellen Probleme tatsächlich
anzugehen und da gibt es einige
Infrastruktur ist ein Punkt
geopolitische Risiken adressieren ist
ein anderer Punkt wir haben fachkräftem
der auch Arbeitskräftemangel werden wird
also wir haben eine demografische
Entwicklung die eigentlich dazu führen
wird dass der Faktor Arbeit knapp wird
und das schränkt das Wachstumspotenzial
ein also strukturell das ist kein
konjunkturelles Problem sondern eine
Wachstumsschwäche die wir reinlaufen
könnten und da muss man jetzt mit
Maßnahmen gegen anarbeiten einerseits
Investitionen Anreizen erstmal muss man
ja den Gedanken verstehen als solchen
ich will noch mal fragen warum trifft es
ausgerechnet Deutschland jetzt so hart
und warum sind ausgerechnet wir von den
Industrieländern eben die die nicht
wachsen ja wir haben eben eine sehr
energieintensive Industrie das hat uns
stark gemacht aber das führt auch dazu
dass wir sehr viel transformations
Herausforderungen haben weil diese
energieintensive Industrie muss ich
jetzt neu erfinden müssen Umstellen von
Gas Öl auf erneuerbaren Wasserstoff und
Strom Elektrifizierung und das sind
Aufgaben die auch dazu führen werden
dass ich Strukturen ändern und das
Auswirkungen
Transformation hat Auswirkungen auf die
Menschen die sind diesmal nicht
arbeitslos aber sie werden ärmer sie
werden sukzessive ärmer also ich glaube
es ist schon so dass wir sehen müssen
dass wir nicht so weitermachen können
wie bisher sondern dass ich viel tun
muss und dass man auch eine gewisse
Veränderungsbereitschaft in der
Bevölkerung auslösen muss und auch den
Glauben daran auslösen muss das ist dann
weitergeht wir werden nicht jetzt die
die hohen Energiekosten Weg fördern
können und dann so weitermachen wie
bisher weil sich ja strukturell so viel
ändert also wir werden sehen müssen wie
sich die Industrie neu aufstellt wie wir
damit umgehen dass wir weniger
Arbeitskräfte zur Verfügung haben das
bedeutet einerseits Arbeitskräfte zu
mobilisieren auch Erwerbsbeteiligung zu
mobilisieren und auf der anderen Seite
Zuwanderung auszulösen Umfang der höher
ist als bisher und so einfach die
Wirtschaft wieder in Schwung zu bringen
das klingt nach einem ganz großen Kosmos
sind schon Herausforderungen den wir uns
jetzt stellen müssen weil davon wird
angegangen aber ich glaube wir müssen
auch noch viel konsequenter werden und
dann sind wir genauso dankbar dass
Marcel fratcher bei uns ist die
iw-präsident Ökonom Sie Herr fratsche
warnen davor Panik zu machen und haben
trotzdem eine Erklärung dafür warum wir
dann das Land in Europa sind oder das
Industrieland sind das als einziges
nicht wächst auch an Sie die Frage
zuerst einmal wieso wachsen wir nicht
Veronika Grimm mal einige Gründe genannt
man kann auch als weiteren Gründen in
die Offenheit der deutschen
Volkswirtschaft es gibt kaum eine
Industrieland von der Größe das so stark
von den Exporten abhängt die Hälfte
unserer Wirtschaftsleistung sind Exporte
und die Weltwirtschaft im Augenblick
läuft nicht rund das heißt wir haben
massiven Einbruch gerade daher auch bei
den Industrieunternehmen und wir haben
diese Kombination von relativ hohen
Inflation auch die konsumschwäche ist
wichtig
denn viele Menschen haben Lohnerhöhung
erfahren die weit unter der Inflation
liegen müssen Gürtel enger schnallen
auch die konsumschwäche ist wichtig aber
für mich sehr entscheidende Faktor auch
noch mal daran zu schließen so ein
bisschen die jetzige wirtschaftliche
Schwäche im Perspektive zu setzen
deutschland hat in 2010er Jahren ein
enorm erfolgreiches Jahrzehnt gehabt die
Unternehmen sind gewachsen am
Marktanteile ausgebaut global wir haben
Beschäftigung aufgebaut die Löhne sind
gestiegen das war extrem erfolgreich in
Deutschland so ein bisschen auch Opfer
des eigenen Erfolgs viele Transformation
beispielsweise eine aut die Branche
wurden einfach verschlafen und meine
große Sorge heute ist dass ich finde es
interessant dass wir sehr gut darin sind
und schlecht zu reden Wirtschaft hat
viel mit Psychologie mit Vertrauen zu
tun Unternehmerinnen Unternehmer
investiert nicht wenn sie nicht gewisses
Grundvertrauen darin haben dass es
wirtschaftlich eine gute Perspektive
gibt dass es sich lohnt zu investieren
und wo man Herzog hat das 1997 das
Bundespräsident mal eine unglaublich
mentale Depression genannt nicht sehr
unähnlich zu der Situation heute also so
wirtschaftlich eine schwierigen Phase
und
wir reden wir reden nämlich schlecht
Olaf Scholz ist besteht die Gefahr dass
wir das Land schlecht reden das ist nun
tatsächlich eine gute Frage um sie
weiterzugeben wie viel davon Psychologie
ist also wie viel wir uns davon
einbilden und wie viel es tatsächlich
auch harte Fakten sind ich würde als
erstes vielleicht gerne Klaus Ruhe
Matzen fragen wollen die Frau Huberts
auch als Unternehmer gestartet und dann
als Seiteneinsteiger der Quereinsteiger
in die Politik Wirtschaftsminister
Schleswig-Holstein heute sind wir der
kranke Mann Europas wie der Economist
schreibt was würden Sie Antworten also
ich würde nicht vom kranken Mann
sprechend möglicherweise vom dicken Mann
ich habe ein bisschen das Gefühl dass
wir überladen sind dass wir wieder in
die Trainingshose einsteigen sollten Sie
übergewichtig ja wir haben zu viel zu
viel Bürokratie gesetzeverordnungen es
macht ja für vielen Unternehmerinnen und
Unternehmer kaum noch Spaß Unternehmer
zu sein ich glaube das ist ein riesen
Problem wir sind viel zu träge viel zu
langsam geworden wenn ich hungrig ist
ist nicht innovativ wir erfinden uns
nicht neu uns gefällt Transformationen
nicht irgendwie wollen wir doch lieber
uns zurücklehnen und sagen wir waren
doch schon immer gut und ich glaube das
ist mit eher der Gefahr den wir im
Moment haben wir sponnen auch nicht dazu
an dass wir Innovation aufgreifen und
das wir ein bisschen Mut haben mir fehlt
Mut wir haben die letzten Jahre immer
wieder neue schlimme Wörter
kennengelernt wir sind so versunken in
German Angst statt irgendwie die Chancen
zu erkennen also das so ein bisschen der
alte gut alte Sprichwort wir schauen
nach den Löchern die Cases statt nach
der Käse das finde ich wirklich sehr
ärgerlich deswegen ich glaube auch viel
ist ein ein mentales aber wir haben auch
Bürokratie das versteht kein Mensch wenn
man also
nochmal Wirtschaftsminister
Schleswig-Holstein ihnen müssen doch
auch ihre Unternehmer rückmelden dass
sie 20 prozentige Industrie Rückgänge
haben dass ihnen die Materialien fehlen
die Arbeitskräfte fehlen so sie müssen
ja irgendwie auch alarmierende
Botschaften aus der
schleswig-holsteinischen Industrie haben
oder haben sie die nicht jede Woche bei
Unternehmerinnen und Unternehmer und das
wunderbare ist dass die Menschen
deutlich optimistischer sind als wir in
der Debatte wenn man mit den unterwegs
sind dann sagen sie schaffen sie uns
verlässliche Rahmenbedingungen
Zuversicht dann kommen wir klar wir sind
Unternehmerinnen und Unternehmer wir
finden unseren Weg lieber Herr Matzen
aber helfen Sie uns bei dem Thema
Fachkräfte also da setzen sie schon an
und sagen da sehen wir ein Problem dass
uns persönlich freundlich zu ihnen
auch das geht ganz gut die haben
Auftragsbücher sie haben ja sie finden
an in eine Krise entsteht ja auch neue
Möglichkeiten und ein guter
Unternehmerin oder Unternehmer erkennt
Möglichkeiten nur ich muss natürlich
Zuversicht haben geht es jetzt rein in
den Kartoffel oder raus aus den
Kartoffeln und das Gefühl was viele
Unternehmerinnen haben ist das
Deutschland im Moment keinen Strategie
hat keinen Plan wo geht es hin und wie
wollen wir dahin kommen das glaube ich
ist die Ansage die wir alle benötigen
und in dem Moment kann der Mensch sich
auch darauf einstellen wie im Moment
sind wir aber eher unsicher also
Zuversicht braucht man ich glaube also
wie gesagt Deutschland ist eher der
dicke Mann und da sollten wir ändern ab
in die Sporthalle und dann sehen wir
auch zu dass wir wieder nach vorne okay
Marie Christian Ostermann ist bei uns
das finden wir natürlich genauso gut und
freuen uns dass Sie als Unternehmerin
für die Familienunternehmer insgesamt
180.000 in diesem Land sprechen sie
haben ihre Partei Mitgliedschaft bei der
FDP ohne lassen für dieses Amt und sie
arbeiten in haben bei einem Lebensmittel
Großhandel jetzt ist Jammern des immer
ganz groß warum würden Sie sagen Frau
Ostermann dass man dieses jammern der
Unternehmer diesmal ganz genau und ganz
aufmerksam verfolgen sollte ja ich würde
es nicht als jammern bezeichnen sondern
einfach klar und deutlich wird über
Klartext benannt was schief läuft in
diesem Land und wir sind von den Kosten
her einfach viel viel zu teuer zu hohe
Energiepreise dann der krasse
Arbeitskräftemangel wir sind bei
Innovationen rückständig und hinten
hinterher und das liegt daran dass wir
im Prinzip seit über 15 Jahren keine
strukturellen Reformen in diesem Land
erlebt haben die uns wieder
wettbewerbsfähig gemacht hätten und für
Unternehmer und Privatinvestoren ist es
wie schon gesagt wichtig verlässliche
Rahmenbedingungen zu haben dass man das
Muh den Mut und den hat das Vertrauen
hat wirklich am Standort zu investieren
und dafür wäre es anstelle von
Subventionen industriestrompreis wo viel
darüber gesprochen wird die aber nur
kurzfristig als Strohfeuer wirken wäre
es wichtig wirklich strukturelle Reform
durchzuführen die Probleme an der Wurzel
packen beispielsweise sagen meine
Arbeitnehmer dass ich Arbeit für sie
viel zu wenig lohnt sie müssten viel
mehr Netto vom Brutto auf dem Konto
letztendlich haben für die ganze
Anstrengung und wir bräuchten dringend
eine wirklich große mutige Steuerreform
für Arbeitnehmer aber auch für
Arbeitgeber damit sie wieder den Mut
haben in den Standort zu investieren und
wir brauchen einfachere Bedingungen das
Fachkräfte wirklich ins Land kommen und
diesen Standort attraktiv finden ich
habe selbst im Ausland studiert die
sagen auch das Land ist zu teuer ich
erlebt viel zu wenig Netto vom Brutto
was übrig bleibt das Bildungssystem ist
marode Inflation noch dazu das darf man
auch nicht vergessen Menschen haben drei
du hast drei Jahre hintereinander
tatsächlich mit Inflation zu kämpfen und
das ist eben ein Vermögens Einbruch also
da geht Vermögen und Einkommen Weg genau
und die Inflation ist ja nicht dabei
deutlich runter zu gehen was auch damit
zusammenhängt dass die Kosten im Land
einfach nach wie vor viel viel zu hoch
sind beim Energieangebot beispielsweise
ist einfach zu knapp aus Atomenergie
sind wir aus gestiegen wir müssten jetzt
wirklich massiv mehr in Erneuerbare
Energien investieren Bürokratie abbauen
Genehmigungsverfahren beschleunigen auch
sie haben einen ganz schönen
Blumenstrauß oder ein ganz schönes Buch
zusammen unter dem Begriff
Angebotspolitik Rahmenbedingungen
schaffen das Investoren wieder mutig am
Standort investieren und das Angebot
ausweiten dann sinken auch die Preise
und das was die Ampel da jetzt in
Meseberg beschlossen hat das ist ja sind
ja ganz viele kleinere Gesetze die
Abschreibungsmöglichkeiten
Investitionsanreize würden Sie sagen
irgendetwas davon hilft Ihrer Firma
jetzt tatsächlich durch diese Zeit zu
kommen tatsächlich die
Abschreibungsmöglichkeit degressive
Abschreibung bedeutet Prozent
steuerabschreibung verlustig ich kann
also Kosten für Investitionen steuerlich
viel besser schneller geltend machen das
bedeutet dass Unternehmen schneller
reinvestieren können Kapital nehmen
können um es zu investieren in
Produktionsmittel in Innovation und
dadurch wieder Wertschöpfung zu schaffen
und auch Steuereinnahmen zu
erwirtschaften das ist eine eine große
Hilfe für die Unternehmen speziell nicht
für mein Unternehmen weil wir keine
Verluste gemacht haben aber für andere
ist auch die flexible Verlustverrechnung
sehr sehr hilfreich dass sie eben
Verluste mit vorherigen gewinnen auch
verrechnen können das ist ein Schritt in
die richtige Richtung es ist ein Anfang
aber es ist nur ein kleiner Schritt es
müssten deutlich größere mutigere
Schritte folgen um dieses Land wieder
wettbewerbsfähig zu machen nun ist ja
auch so interessant Frau Grimm was in
Meseberg alles nicht besprochen wurde
das klang an diesem schlauen Tisch hier
schon an nämlich beispielsweise dass wir
diese wahnsinnig hohen Energiepreise
haben und dass uns die hohen
Energiepreise natürlich auch um es
salopp zu sagen in diese schlechtere
Wettbewerbssituation stellen es wird
diskutiert dass wir
subventionieren dass wir diese hohen
Preise für die Industrie subventionieren
da hat sich der Wirtschaftsminister
Robert Habeck zusammen mit
der SPD-Fraktion und natürlich den
Grünen stark gemacht für genau eine
solche
Subvention des Strompreises für die
energieintensive Industrie schauen wir
mal
ist die Zeit der energieintensiven
Industrien Deutschland bald vorbei
besonders bei neuen stromverträgen
müssen Betriebe tief in die Tasche
greifen in Frankreich Zahlen Unternehmen
ein Drittel des deutschen Preises in den
USA ein Viertel und in China ein siebte
drei Länder die weiter auf Atomkraft
setzen
es ist ein historischer Fehler aus der
Atomkraft auszusteigen
AKWs runtergefahren kein billiges
russisches Gas mehr und hohe
Energiesteuern es ist ein toxischer Mix
wir haben in allen energieintensiven
Bereichen erhebliche Rückschritte der
Produktion gegenüber dem vorherigen
Niveau von fast 20 Prozent das hat sich
noch nicht korrigiert es geht um
energieintensive Industrieunternehmen
die stehen richtig unter Stress und
jetzt sind sie derzeit auch nur kaum
wenn überhaupt wettbewerbsfähig was tun
SPD-Fraktion und Grüne fordern einen
industriestrompreis von 5 Cent für fünf
Jahre
privatkundenzeiten dann das Siebenfache
Kanzler und Finanzminister lehnen das ab
und die SPD-Fraktion ist
interessanterweise dafür Frau Huberts
jetzt kann man genau an diesem Beispiel
vielleicht ganz gut erklären worin
Deutschland ein Problem hat die
SPD-Fraktion ist dafür der
Wirtschaftsminister unterstützt es sehr
es gibt natürlich Teile der Industrie
die das vehement fordern dass es für die
energieintensiven Firmen einen
Strompreis geben soll warum soll es den
für
22440 Unternehmen geben und für die
kleine Bäckerei um die Ecke nicht wir
müssen ja mal verstehen warum das so
wichtig ist Unternehmen treffen jetzt
Standort Entscheidungen wo und wie sie
investieren sollen bei den
energieintensiven sogenannten
Kunststoffindustrie da geht es um Chemie
da geht es um klares um Aluminium um
Kupfer um eben das was wir brauchen um
Windräder Autos oder Mikrochips eben zu
bauen die haben sehr hohe Stromkosten
und wir müssen den jetzt eine Brücke
bauen vom jetzt in die Zukunft damit sie
eben nicht abwandern bis eben genug
günstiger erneuerbarer Strom für alle da
ist und der Kanzler und das möchte ich
hier an der Stelle auch sagen hat gesagt
er ist gegen eine dauer-subvention aber
es soll ja auch keine Dauer Subvention
sein sondern wirklich die nächsten Jahre
überbrücken bis wir eben genug
erneuerbare haben und Atomkraft das will
ich hier auch noch mal ganz deutlich
sagen wir hatten sechs Prozent der
ganzen Strommenge war beim Ausstieg aus
AKWs wie exportieren ja sogar Strom nach
Frankreich mein Wahlkreis ist direkt
gegenüber der Grenze von Trier und wie
störanfällig das Gerät ist also das ist
eine Rolle rückwärts das ist nicht die
Zukunft und warum geben wir jetzt nicht
Vollgas dass wir sowohl kein AKW Strom
brauchen als auch genug erneuerbare
haben dass es auch später für alle
günstiger wird aber die
Grundstoffindustrie die müssen wir jetzt
hier halten AKW zünden wir gleich noch
mal die Rakete aber zurück ihnen ist
bewusst dass das durchaus umstritten ist
und wenn sich der Vizekanzler sehr dafür
aber der Bundeskanzler und der
Finanzminister dagegen aussprechen das
ist so enden kann wie häufig in der
Ampel nämlich dass dieser
industriestrompreis nicht kommt
wie groß wäre diese Katastrophe das ist
eine riesenkatastrophe weil es jetzt um
den Wirtschaftsstandort Deutschlands
geht und sie schütteln gerade so ein
bisschen mit dem Kopf aber für uns als
SPD-Bundestagsfraktion bedeutet aktive
Wirtschaftspolitik auch zu gestalten zu
sagen was müssen wir hier halten was
müssen wir neu ansiedeln und wie
gestalten wir auch diesen Wandel damit
uns hier auch nicht alles wegbricht und
deswegen nehmen wir jetzt die Zeit um
die nächsten Wochen auch ernsthaft
Gespräche zu führen Menschen zu
überzeugen und Politik bedeutet auch
Ringen um Ideen so dann muss man auch
noch dazu sagen Rheinland-Pfalz gleich
wir gehen Land
BASF um die Ecke natürlich macht der
Verband auch entsprechend Musik was
würden Sie noch mal die Frage was werden
Sie tun wenn es dazu nicht kommt denken
sie über Alternativen nach die ja auch
Lösungen sein könnten vielleicht für
sogar alle Menschen in diesem Land die
Strompreise weiter zu sehen natürlich
müssen wir auch was dafür tun dass die
kleinen und mittelständischen
Unternehmen auch entlastet werden dass
auch die Bürgerinnen und Bürger aber
Alternative ist ja zu sagen wir wollen
die Stromsteuer einfach mal runter das
wäre Gießkanne das wäre für alle und vor
allen Dingen die energieintensiven
stehen im internationalen Wettbewerb so
aber jetzt so ist es ein Soli für die
Großindustrie das kriegen sie verkauft
zu Hause es ist nein das ist kein Soli
für die Großindustrie es ist ein Soli
für eine gezielte
Wirtschaftsförderung da wo man ansonsten
den Laden dicht macht und vor allen
Dingen viele kleine hängenden an den
großen wenn nämlich die Chemie wegbricht
dann gibt es eben auch die ganze
Zulieferindustrie dahinter die dann die
nächsten Wertschöpfungsketten und waren
Stufen bewerkstelligen müssen die hängen
ja damit drin das sind 2,4 Millionen
Arbeitsplätze im kompletten Land so das
ist ein eindeutiges pro Jahr finanziert
also da stehen ja Zahlen von 30
Milliarden oder sogar noch mehr im Raum
dass das kostet und all die anderen
Unternehmen müssten diese
Subventionierung ja über höre Schulden
und dann höre Steuern finanzieren und
bezahlen dass ich finde das ist eine
ganz krasse Wettbewerbsverzerrung für
den breiten Mittelstand und ich finde
wir brauchen eine Politik die es allen
Unternehmen in Deutschland unabhängig
von Größe und Branche ermöglicht hier
wettbewerbsfähig zu sein denn ansonsten
wird die Abwanderung noch viel viel
krasser sein wenn eben die ganzen
anderen Unternehmen es gibt 40.000
produzierende Unternehmen in Deutschland
und wir reden über 2.000 für diesen
industriestrompreis die dann
abwandern würden oder da steht dem Raum
im Vergleich zu 40.000 insgesamt also
ich denke es wäre eine viel viel größere
Katastrophe wenn dieser
industriestrompreis käme und die anderen
Unternehmen die ja auch mit den großen
im Wettbewerb auch stehen das auch noch
mitbezahlen müssen bei den sowieso schon
sehr schlechten Standortbedingungen für
die tun wir ja auch was die Sekunde wir
fahren gleich Sekunde Sekunde jetzt ist
erstmal
Schleswig-Holstein dran weil auch da ist
ja interessant sie sind in einer grünen
schwarzen Koalition
wie diskutieren sieht es mit den Grünen
was sagt eigentlich Schleswig-Holstein
dazu brauchen wir einen subventionierten
Strompreis für die Großindustrie nein
ich glaube als erstes müssen wir auf
jeden Fall einen Phänomen festhalten was
wir haben nämlich dass wir auf der eine
Seite Produkte mit Steuern und Abgaben
belegen um dann in anderen Seite
irgendwie zu sagen wir kommen euch
entgegen und entlasten das ist eine
super wichtiger Punkt
und jetzt merken wir dass es ganz schön
teuer ist und dass es uns in Teilen
sogar schadet und zwar mächtig schadet
und wenn wir jetzt eben davon sprachen
wie kriegen wir Deutschland den Gang
dann wäre es vielleicht der richtige
Ansatz sich zu überlegen ob das ein gute
es ist das zu belegen um dann danach
hier und da jemanden zu entlasten das
glaube ich ist ein schlechte Ansatz
sondern wir brauchen ein viel Freiraum
und besseren Markt erstens und ja wenn
man schon aus Schleswig-Holstein ist
dann ist es natürlich so dass man stark
dafür wäre dass wir den erneuerbaren
Energie auch dort wo er entsteht zu den
Preisen die entsteht den Unternehmen
anbieten könnte weil heute haben wir ja
ein völlig ungerechtigtes System wo wir
185% erneuerbare Energie in
Schleswig-Holstein haben aber aufgrund
unseres Systems abgaben die höchsten
Preise in Deutschland zahlen dabei haben
wir aber eigentlich den preiswertesten
Energie aber man könnte sagen dort wo
Energie entsteht wäre es auch
intelligent anzusiedeln dann kann ich
preiswerten Energie bekommen das wäre
ein schöner und gesunder Wettbewerb nun
gibt es natürlich da oben ganz viele
Windräder und nicht ganz so viel
Industrie wie im Süden sie könnten ja
den Spieß auch umdrehen und sagen wir
siedeln jetzt an wie verrückt ja genau
also sowohl als auch noch erstens haben
wir auch Betriebe die heute schon ein
deutlich höheren Strompreis haben als
andere das ist ja wie auch eben gesagt
nicht fair und auch nicht gerecht und
wenn wir wirklich ins Transformation
haben wollen wenn wir Akzeptanz haben
wollen was mit den Menschen die da
draußen leben wo sehr viel
Windkraftanlagen aufgestellt wurden
selbstverständlich sie haben heute den
höchsten Strompreis und das kann Ihnen
ja niemanden erklären erstens
intelligent wie zum Beispiel in Dänemark
ist es so die meist geladene App ist ein
energie-app auf die können Sie sehen
wann ist preiswerten Strom zu bekommen
sie wissen also ganz genau wenn Sie
heute um 14 Uhr die Waschmaschine
anschmeißen kriegen sie sogar Geld weil
sie Strom nutzen oder Sie laden Ihr Auto
also wir müssen intelligenter mit
unserer Energie umgehen und dann
natürlich dort wo entsteht auch anbieten
man kann auch direkt
Entgelte Entschuldigung wir brauchen
jetzt die Netzentgelt weil die Netze
müssen gebaut werden natürlich möchten
Sie wieder Markus Söder auffordern dass
er ein bisschen in die Strümpfe kommen
soll darf ich das so übersetzen ich
würde es anders sagen wir wollen
Menschen motivieren eine Energiewende
wir wollen an Akzeptanz für erneuerbare
Energien denn müssen wir doch dadurch
schaffen dass jeder sagt ich habe auch
ein Vorteil wenn bei mir viel
erneuerbare Energie entsteht ich glaube
das wird natürlich auch nicht abstreiten
es gibt ja auch Bereiche in Bayern indem
man auch ganz gut ausgebaut hat aber ich
glaube wenn Deutschland insgesamt diesen
Weg gehen will dann wollen wir doch
motivieren das wurde auch eben gesagt
kommen müssen die Preise runter und der
sagen sie essen über erstmal müssen die
Preise die Energiepreise erstmal
brauchen wir ein fairer Politik also
warum legen wir es Steuern und Abgaben
das können wir doch erstmal so weit ist
in Europa möglich ist runterbringen
erstmal diesen Level schaffen dann
können wir
über diese Netzentgelte ein fairen
Verteilung bringen und dann haben wir
doch einen fairen Wettbewerb für sowohl
der kleine der mittlere aber auch das
Großunternehmen auch ein großes
Unternehmen muss sich ja der
Rahmenbedingungen stellen dabei braucht
einen Plan so und dann sind wir jetzt
bei den beiden
Wirtschaftswissenschaftlern und Fragen
einmal Frau Grimm ob sie eigentlich für
oder gegen diesen subventionierten
Strompreis sind für die ja die intensive
Industrie ich finde das sehr
problematisch es gibt zwei Effekte den
einen der einen angesprochen worden
nämlich dass der ja von irgendjemand
bezahlt werden muss entweder über
Schulden also von der zukünftigen
Generation oder über Steuern Abgaben
heute
durch die durch die anderen gezahlt
werden das zweite ist dass man natürlich
durch einen so vergünstigten Strompreis
die Nachfrage der energieintensiven
Industrie erhöht und das erhöht den
Strompreis am Markt und das erhöht dann
noch mal den Strompreis für alle anderen
für alle zukunftsorientierten
innovativen Unternehmen die dann
schlechtere Standortbedingungen haben
und auch für alle Haushalte und das ist
glaube keine gute Idee vor allen Dingen
weil wir ja in diese Industrie mal
reingucken muss es wird da ja ein
Strukturwandel geben müssen wir werden
ja diese energieintensive Produktion
nicht vollumfänglich bei uns behalten
können es wird da sicherlich
Verlagerungen gehen aber vielleicht
nicht der ganzen Industrien sondern der
energieintensiv produzierten Vorprodukte
zum Beispiel Wasserstoff ich will ja
nicht das Wasserstoff mit Hilfe von
Strom in Deutschland vollumfänglich für
den deutschen Verbrauch produziert wird
sondern es ist ja ohnehin der Plan dass
man zwei Drittel das Wasserstoffs 2030
schon importiert das sind große Mengen
das müsste man lostreten das
Energieangebot lostreten des
Energieangebot auch der Stromangebot
ausbauen massiv dafür brauchen in
Deutschland halten
an welcher Stelle man Import
substituierte in der Krise haben wir
auch gesehen ammonia z.B ist Import
subsidiert worden aber ja kann man einen
sehr sehr viel Standorten weltweit
produzieren ist kein Grund dafür da den
in Deutschland zu produzieren wir können
den aus allen möglichen Regionen in der
Welt importieren auch klimaneutral
produziert dann muss man eben die
entsprechen den konditionschaften
auch unbedingt dazu gehört und dann
gehen wir in die Battle sie würden sagen
dass das auch eine gute oder eine
eigentlich schädliche Investition
politische Investitionen wäre dahin
jetzt 30 Milliarden oder 50 Milliarden
zu geben über einen begrenzten Zeitraum
erst einmal muss man anerkennen dass es
hier kein Schwarz und Weiß gibt kein
richtig und falsch es ist gewisser Weise
reden wir alle mit viel Unsicherheit wie
es wirkt ich bin bei Veronika Grimm bei
Ihnen das ist die Energiekosten erhöhen
wird für alle die den Strom diese
subventilierten strommeche halten aber
bin bei Voba zu sagen die Industrie ist
eine zentrale Stärke der deutschen
Wirtschaft sie schafft viele gute
Arbeitsplätze viel Innovation wovon die
Wirtschaft profitiert ich sehe den
industriestrompreis auch kritisch nicht
nur aus den genannten Gründen sondern
auch die Frage was ist denn das beste
Instrument um den betroffenen
Unternehmen zu helfen dass man die
unterstützt ist meine Ansicht nach
völlig richtig nur für mich sind jetzt
zwei Dinge wichtig einmal zu sagen ist
es wirklich nur über Stromkosten werden
über Rahmenbedingungen gesprochen also
eigentlich würden die gleichen
Unternehmen hinaus sagen wir brauchen
weniger Regulierung wir brauchen eine
bessere Infrastruktur wir brauchen
Fachkräfte also da wäre das viel bessere
Instrumente sagen wir nutzen etwas
anderes und das zweite ist was glaube
ich das ist ganz schwer fällt auch der
Politik ich bin sehr skeptisch darüber
wenn die Politik anfängt zu sagen das
Unternehmen soll überleben das
Unternehmen gehört gefördert das aber
nicht also die Politik sollte
Rahmenbedingungen setzen ja sie kann
punktuell Schwerpunkte setzen wie bei
grünem Stahl da tut er gibt es ja große
Subventionen bei Batterietechnik aber es
muss wirklich punktuell sein ich würde
sehr vorsichtig sein wenn die Politik
anfängt wirklich eine Industriepolitik
zu machen wo sie Gewinner und Verlierer
wählen bestimmte Bereiche und für ja und
deshalb es gibt bessere Instrumente ich
ich teile das Ziel ich glaube es ist
ganz wichtig aber ich glaube es gibt
bessere Instrumente als den
Industriestrom aber jetzt muss man sich
ja die verlangt derjenigen anschauen die
dafür plädieren es waren ganz
ursprünglich mal alle
Ministerpräsidenten es war ganz
ursprünglich auch mal der
Kanzlerkandidat Olaf Scholz warum sieht
es der Kanzler Scholz jetzt anders wäre
die Frage was glauben sie hat sehr viele
durchaus auch noch Dinge die geklärt
werden müssen in Europa
verfassungsrechtlich aber da machen wir
gerade auch unsere Hausaufgaben und wo
ein Wille da ein Weg und da kann man ja
auch mal als Motor des Kontinents
überzeugen frankreich hat ja auch einen
industriestrompreis ja frankreich hat
aber insgesamt niedrigere Strompreise
als wir und dann sind wir eben insgesamt
niedrigere und dann sind wir noch mal
bei der Frage 2,4 Millionen
Arbeitsplätze malt der BDI an die Wand
und sagt es ist eben nicht nur diese
energieintensive Industrie sondern es
hängt ja metallverarbeiten dran Glas es
hängt Keramikindustrie mit dran wir
würden insgesamt Größenordnung 200
Milliarden Wertschöpfung aus dem Land
schieben wäre das egal in ihren Augen
nein das das wäre nicht egal aber da bin
ich wieder beim Thema
Vertrauen und Panik mache also ich
glaube man muss eben auch ein bisschen
realistisch darauf schauen es ist
sicherlich also Herr Hüter sagt ja auch
20 % ist ja natürlich haben wir diese
Einbrüche aber ich will noch einen
anderen Punkt machen also die Sorge ist
ja völlig gerechtfertigt dass man sagt
wir sind da ist eine Industrien gefahren
aber müssen sehr genau unterscheiden
diesem Punkt implizit gemacht das Ziel
einer Wirtschaftspolitiker von
Unternehmen kann es nicht sein die
Produktion per se in Deutschland zu
halten oder zu zementieren Ziel für eine
für Wohlstand in einer Gesellschaft muss
es sein gute Arbeitsplätze und
Innovationsfähigkeit zu erhalten und
wenn Ammoniak das war das Beispiel von
Veronika Grimm besser im Ausland
produziert werden kann günstiger um das
Unternehmen effizienter zu machen im
globalen Wettbewerb wettbewerbsfähiger
dann ist es gut wenn Unternehmen
Produktion ins Ausland verlagert wir
müssen weg von diesen denken wir müssen
alles einheimisch produzieren
Unternehmen sind erfolgreich wenn sie
sich global aufstellen und deshalb
müssen wir Transformation heißt
Veränderung zulassen ja es werden auch
einzelne Arbeitsplätze verloren gehen
aber wenn wir langfristig Arbeitsplätze
sichern müssen wir diese Veränderung
kurzfristig auch zulassen das heißt wir
sehen dann zu dass es diese industrielle
Veränderung gibt und dass die alten
Industrie Jobs eben gehen weil man
chemische Industrie Metallindustrie in
den USA in besser machen jemand noch mal
ein Beispiel bASF hat jetzt ein Teil in
der energieintensiven Produktion ins
Ausland Verlagen heißt es oh Gott da
haben wir jetzt eine die
Industrialisierung für BASF ist das
genau die richtige Entscheidung die
müssen sich global aufstellen und wenn
die Energie intensive Produktion im
Ausland günstiger machen können dann
hilft das auch Arbeitsplätze von BASF in
Deutschland zu sichern aber sie
beschweren sich ja sie sagen ja wir
würden lieber hier bleiben es wäre ja
viel besser wenn ihr mal die Strompreise
senken würde natürlich was erwarten sie
von Unternehmen natürlich wollen die die
bestmöglichen finanziellen Bedingungen
aber da muss die Politik sicher ein
Stück unabhängig machen und sagen alle
Unternehmen haben legitime Interessen
die Politik muss eine gute Distanz war
sie muss gute Rahmenbedingungen für
alles schaffen für ein Wettbewerb
zulassen und darf nicht sagen sie
kriegen die Hilfe die anderen Kriegen es
nicht
direkt Verträge gerade für wollen
Energie das wäre eine
marktwirtschaftliche Lösung das heißt
das hätten sie noch mal übersetzen
Produzenten von grüner Energie könnten
an Abnehmer an Nachfrage direkt an
andere denken individuellen Vertrag
aushandeln
und es darauf könnten Steuern und
Abgaben weitestgehend auch gesenkt
werden vom Staat das würde gerade den
Ausbau der erneuerbaren Energien auch
noch mal befeuern es wäre eine
marktwirtschaftliche Lösung die am
effizientesten und kostengünstigsten wir
müssen eigentlich in großem Umfang eben
genau diese energieintensiven Produkte
die ja Vorprodukte in den entsprechenden
Industrien sind da müssen wir eben
schaffen die in großen Umfang zu
importieren und zwar diversifiziert wenn
BASF das für sich tut dann tun die das
vielleicht in China und dann denken wir
gleich wieder aus geopolitischen Gründen
ups das wollen wir vielleicht nicht in
dem Umfang was eigentlich auch ein
Anspruch der Regierung sein müsste ist
zu organisieren dass wir diversifiziert
beziehen große Mengen an klimaneutraler
Energie also Wasserstoff darauf
basierende Energieträger e-fuels und
zwar aus verschiedensten Märkten
weltweit und das schöne ist ja bei der
Produktion von klimaneutralen
Energieträgern das kann man an viel mehr
Orten machen als heute Orte gibt wo wir
fossile Energieträger überall da
importieren weil darmstoffe sind und die
kann man nicht einfach aber das da gibt
es ja aber da gibt es ja viel Forschung
und diese aber dafür Zeit kaufen diese
Lieferketten ja aber das sollte man
jetzt sehr sehr schnell anschieben weil
wenn die Erwartung da ist seitens der
Unternehmen dass diese Energie 2030
verfügbar ist an den entsprechenden
Standorten dann investiert man natürlich
wenn die Erwartung da ist das wird nicht
gelingen dann geht man mit der darauf
aufbauenden Produktion ins Ausland aber
diese Erwartung müssen wir auch bei uns
halten können das ist doch total
kurzsichtig wie sie argumentieren man
kann nicht alles über einen
Containerschiff packen und wir wollen es
doch jetzt hier halten und natürlich
sagen wir auch nicht die Welt kann
bleiben wie sie ist wir gehen ja mit
diesen Unternehmen in den Wandel wir
machen den Grünen Stahl und werden ihn
ja auch noch mal mit grenzzahlen z.B CO2
basiert dann auch dafür sorgen dass man
nicht einfach den dreckigen grauen Stahl
aus China mal eben rüberkacht also das
ist alles nicht kurzsichtig und deswegen
müssen wir die Brücke bauen und dafür
sorgen dass wir natürlich auch für alle
anderen Anreize schaffen dass der Strom
günstiger wird zum Beispiel ist ja ein
großes Problem wie der Marktpreis sich
bestimmt merit order haben wir alle
kennengelernt jetzt ist es das
norwegische Gas das ist besonders teuer
ist richtig also die günstigen Preise
der Erneuerbaren also Wind Sonne die
können gar nicht durchschlagen da müssen
wir mal raten wir haben ja auch gesehen
wir haben zum Beispiel die EEG-Umlage
abgeschafft hat 20 Milliarden Entlastung
für den Mittelstand gebracht hat sich
bei mir noch keiner bedankt weil
natürlich der unterliegende Preis
einfach so volatil und unplanbar ist es
geht jetzt um Planungssicherheit für
Unternehmen wo sie investieren die
nächsten 10 Jahre das weiß ich noch als
Unternehmerin man macht eine Excel
Tabelle man guckt wo habe ich welche
Bedingungen und wie sind die und da
müssen wir an und jetzt ist noch mal der
Blick auf den Bürger also auf die
Menschen in diesem Land die jetzt nicht
für die Schwerindustrie oder die alte
Großindustrie stehen in diesem
klassischen Sinne der zahlt einen 6 mal
höheren Preis als diese fünf Cent oder
die 6 Cent die sie vorschlagen
zusätzlich zu allen anderen Kosten die
er gerade trägt deswegen müssen wir die
externiert eine Sozialdemokraten
ausgerechnet das wie ich sage natürlich
müssen wir auch was für euch tun dass es
auch für euch günstiger wird indem wir
zum Beispiel unser Strompreis unser
transformationspreis
brückenstrompreiskonzept sieht vor mit
einem Ausbau Bonus zu koppeln damit wir
eben schneller Ausbau Wohnung ein Ausbau
Bonus das auch ein Unternehmen sagt wenn
ich davon jetzt was habe dann werde ich
jetzt auch mich an dem Windpark
beteiligen an einer Solaranlage auf dem
Dach oder auf dem Parkplatz also wir
denken das nicht nur einen dimensional
sondern wie erwarten natürlich auch von
den Unternehmen dass sie sich bei dieser
Energiewende beteiligen denn der
erneuerbare Strom ist günstig und wenn
wir da jetzt mehr Vollgas geben dann
sind wir auch 20:35 Uhr 100% erneuerbar
das ist ein riesen Leistung und es wird
auch günstiger für alle anderen gleich
noch mal ob das wirklich so kommen wird
aber noch mal zurück würden Sie denn
sagen wenn das nicht gelingt noch mal
Frau Hubert es sieht ja gerade gar nicht
danach aus als würde diese Branchen
energieintensive Firmen
gesponserte subventionierte Strompreis
kommen es sind die beiden entscheidenden
Männer in der Regierung noch dagegen und
es gibt eine Opposition die auch eine
ganz anderen Vorschlag macht und die
Ministerpräsidenten sind auf ihrer Seite
das ist interessant das waren sie mal
Stück A16 jetzt sind nur noch sieben was
tun Sie wenn es diesen
industriestrompreis für die
Schwerindustrie nicht gibt wenn der
nicht kommen ich bin in der Politik um
für meine Überzeugung zu kämpfen und ich
weiß man muss dran bleiben auch wenn
schwierig wird und deswegen gehen die
nächsten Wochen und Monate erstmal darum
zu überzeugen und genau für diese Lösung
zu verändern
Industrieunternehmen gibt es insgesamt
in Deutschland wie erklären Sie diesen
dann
37.500 dass sie nicht in den Genuss
eines gesenkten Strompreises kommt man
muss natürlich auch ehrlich sein ich
meine wir haben ja jetzt auch schon die
Debatte der Bäcker gegen die
Großindustrie und wir müssen natürlich
sagen wir können nicht alles künstlich
irgendwie unterstützen wir müssen dem
Bäcker sagen wie kann er denn jetzt auch
an diesem Wandel teilnehmen dass er
seinen Strom durch zum Beispiel
künstlich verteuern das ist ja dann mein
Einstieg gewesen wir haben den
dreifachen Preis von Frankreich und das
diskutieren wir überhaupt nicht mehr
komplett raus aus dem Gedanken dass wir
überhaupt darüber diskutieren wieso sind
wir zu diesem wahnsinnig hohen Preis
gekommen was sind denn die
Preisbestandteile und müssen wir nicht
viel lieber darüber reden das war was
ich vorher gemacht werden magdal heißt
doch erst einmal der Staat kommt doch
nicht den Preis zum dreifachen bringen
und dann sagen jetzt bin ich ganz ganz
wichtig
ja ich schenke euch so ein bisschen
davon weil weil sonst geht ja ja weg
wenn wir erst einmal den richtigen
Marktpreis schaffen würden das ist ja
glaube ich die Grundvoraussetzung die
alle erwarten können und natürlich
müssen wir dann schauen haben wir
bestimmte Industrien auf die wir nicht
verzichten wollen mit
Schlüsseltechnologien die Deutschland
nicht verlieren darf selbstverständlich
voll bei ihnen wir haben auch ganz viele
Produkte die wir weltweit bekommen
können und wo es vielleicht gut ist wenn
Deutschland sich in ein Transformation
befindet zu sagen wo ist unser vor außer
den Netzentgelten konkret was ich
vorschlage ist das was ich eben schon
sagte erst einmal die ganzen Steuern und
Abgaben soweit runter wie es geht wir
leisten dass wir nicht mehr überall
Subventionen zweitens würde ich sagen
wir entlassen die Betriebe in
Wirklichkeiten ohne dass das Geld kostet
mit Bürokratie Entlastung ja aber nicht
ausreichend wir haben 50 Milliarden Euro
deutlich mehr und das ist nämlich
Attraktivität ich war San Francisco hat
mit Unternehmen gesprochen warum ist
hier eigentlich silicon valleys
erfolgreich weil die Politik die
Wirtschaft verstanden hat weil man hier
Sachen ermöglicht weil man nicht immer
im Weg ist weil man nicht immer sagt wir
haben Bedenken wir müssen das überplanen
in Deutschland ist es so dass es zu
jedem Vorhaben ein Möglichkeit gibt ein
Gesetz Paragraph oder ein Urteil zu
finden um was zu verhindern und dann
sitzen Menschen und sagen das mache ich
lieber nicht weil wenn was ermöglicht
wird dann fragt einer wer hat das denn
ermöglicht und wir müssen in eine andere
Welt eintauchen in dem Sachen ermöglicht
wird in denen das kann man auch noch mal
nach Amerika schauen zu Joe Biden der ja
auch 360 Milliarden investiert das ist
ein großer Betrag aber auf den kommt
Deutschland auch und am Ende auch die
Europäischen Union mit ihrem Mentos the
moonprojekt warum Frau Ostermann
begrüßen alle so sehr dieses Projekt und
Programm von Joe Biden und haben das
Gefühl von diesen Riesen Summen die wir
aufwenden ist wenig zu spüren na
insgesamt ist sind die USA schon
attraktives Land für Unternehmer weil
die Unternehmenskultur da sehr
willkommen ist und alle freuen sich
darüber Leistungen und wenn Gewinn
erwirtschaftet wird hier gehen gleich
die Night Debatten los und es wird alles
sehr sehr oft viel negativ gesehen aber
letztendlich verschuldet sich Joe Beine
mit den USA auch sehr sehr stark für das
Subventionsprogramm dort und viele
Amerikaner gucken auch doch auch ein
bisschen mit Neid nach Deutschland weil
wir hier die Schuldenbremse einhalten
weil wir eigentlich bis vor kurzem auch
ein EU eine eu-beihilfenaufsicht hatten
die funktioniert hatte und es ist
einfach extrem wichtig auch Subventionen
zu kontrollieren und auch zu
hinterfragen und entsprechendes
Monitoring da eben auch aber die sind
schnell sie sind unkompliziert sie
machen ganz viel über steuerabschreibung
deshalb fragte ich am Anfang danach also
da kann auch einfacher als irgendwelche
Förderung erstmal sehr bürokratisch und
aufwendig beantragt werden müssen aber
trotzdem sind auch diese Subventionen
dort nur ein kurzfristige Stroh vorher
und nicht was Unternehmen langfristig
haben Standort halten wird langfristig
braucht man einfach strukturelle
Reformen dass die Unternehmen von den
Kosten her aus eigener Kraft wirklich
erfolgreich am Standort sein können nur
wenn das der Fall ist können wir auch
international Vorbild für andere
Nationen auch sein nur wenn wir wirklich
kostengünstig und beispielsweise auch
preiswerte Energie bereitstellen können
werden auch andere Länder folgen und
unserem Beispiel auch folgen wenn wir
einfach viel zu teuer sind und zu
bürokratisch und zu kompliziert und
alles nur langsam und gehemmt wird dann
werden wir niemals Zug fährt und Vorbild
für die Welt und dann
glaube ich müssen wir uns eine Frage
stellen wenn man jetzt Unternehmer
irgendwo auf der Welt ist und man
überlegt sich ob man nach Deutschland
gehen sollte wo würden wir jetzt sagen
sind so unser zwei drei vier Gründe
warum wir unbedingt nach Deutschland
gehen muss weil man das Leben würde auf
jede Behörde die gleiche ja sie sind
Unternehmer und sind sie immer noch
glauben sie machen sie jetzt in dieser
Situation gerne ihr Möbelgeschäft haben
sie Bock sich noch drei andere Sachen
einfallen zu lassen weil es hier so ein
super innovativer und und Boden ist in
Deutschland Liebe würde ich jederzeit
nach wie vor hier Unternehmen gründen
und ich liebe es auch hier Unternehmer
zu sein weil uns geht es auch gut wir
müssen auch aufpassen besonders Energie
intensiv muss man dazu sagen das absolut
aber auch ein Möbelhaus verbraucht
relativ viel Energie und das ist
natürlich ärgerlich wenn ich dann sehe
dass es gekostet hätte wenn dieses
Möbelhaus in Frankreich wäre aber noch
das wollen wir ja jetzt mal eben von weg
wenn ich aber sehe was für eine Latte
hat beauftragte ich in so ein
Unternehmen habe dann wundere ich mir ob
wir uns das leisten können wenn ich die
alle aufzähle dann sitze ich irgendwann
und überlege gibt es überhaupt
irgendjemanden im Möbelhaus der auch
Möbel verkauft und da kommt wieder diese
bürokratieansatz dass wir da nicht
wirklich viel konkreter werden wir
werden auch als Schleswig-Holstein ist
natürlich dieses Jahr noch ein Bundesrat
Initiative einbringen mit konkreten
Vorschlägen weil nochmals wenn jemand
von außerhalb auf Deutschland schaut und
man dann sie müssen wirklich von einem
Behörde zum anderen machen
ein Leben eine E-Mail also und das sind
die gleichen Daten die Sie überall
hinbringen und sie muss das wirklich
sein und dann hören wir das Problem oh
Datenschutz und da habe ich angst ist
das schöner dass jeder von ihnen von mir
die Daten bekommt als dass wir sie
zentral haben und sie greifen darauf zu
ich glaube da diese Diskussion der
Mentalität wir Deutschen wir lieben dass
man uns kontrolliert irgendjemand muss
zuständig sein irgendjemanden
also bloß nicht dass ich das hier
irgendwie alleine klarkommen sondern ich
möchte Zuständigkeiten ich möchte das
mit Paragrafen und Gesetze und wenn in
Deutschland ein Gesetz entsteht durch
sucht jeder nach dem schlupfen und dann
macht der Gesetz das wieder zu genau und
dann wird es immer schlimmer und dann
haben wir so eine überborne Biografie
die wir nicht mehr verstehen wir müssen
also als Menschen auch lernen wenn unser
Bundeskanzler sagt so will ich das
geregelt haben aha ich habe den Sinn
verstanden und muss nicht einen
Schlupfloch suchen nur so kann unsere
Bürokratie etwas einfacher etwas
verständiger werden nur deshalb ist ja
irgendwie unter Tradition jetzt geworden
wir lieben es geregelt zu werden wünscht
sich jeder dahinter steckt natürlich
auch immer ein gewisses Misstrauen
können wir jetzt nicht zu ausführlich
diskutieren ich wollte noch mal auf Nord
kommen es ist gibt eine schwedischen
Batterie Firma um deren Ansiedlung ihr
in Schleswig-Holstein sehr kämpft und
ringt die jetzt auch gesagt haben ob da
die USA sind viel attraktiver für uns
was macht man da was macht
Schleswig-Holstein jetzt also ich
Krempel die Ärmel hoch und tu alles was
ich kann ich rede mit den Schweden wir
diskutieren mit den Schweden haben wir
überlegen natürlich was für
Möglichkeiten gibt es man muss
fairerweise wissen wenn Sie Batterien
produzieren in Amerika nach dem Programm
was es jetzt gibt würde es circa 10.000
Euro Preisunterschied geben zu einem in
Europa produziert ist dass das
Unternehmen von sich aus sagt das klingt
spannend Klaus was könnt ihr denn tun
und wir dann natürlich uns auf dem Weg
machen und uns überlegen müssen ist das
möglicherweise ein Technologie der
Zukunft möchten wir dass Europa grüne
Autobatterien produziert und wenn das
wollen wir das in Deutschland haben und
wenn es in Deutschland möchte ich das in
Schleswig-Holstein haben all das kann
ich mit Japan beantworten weil dann sind
wir wieder bei den Fachkräfte ich möchte
dass die jungen Menschen nicht mehr in
den Süden gehen im Auto bauen sie sollen
in den Norden kommenden Firmen die die
Welt verbessern und deswegen wollen wir
natürlich mit nordwelt ein grünes
Industrieland hat natürlich den Anspruch
zu sagen moderne zukunftsträchtige
Ansiedlungen direkt angedockt an
Windkraftanlagen damit also auch den
Energie den Überschuss wir haben zwei
Terabyte Stunden überschüssige Energie
im Jahr erneuerbar und genau diese
Energie
auf die wir in der Zukunft dann hoffen
um irgendwann das grüne
Wirtschaftswunderland erreicht zu haben
wo der die Strompreise die Energiepreise
ohnehin sinken und wir wieder wachsen
ja ich habe ja wir haben jetzt viel über
die Probleme diskutiert und ich sie noch
gar nicht so richtig ja weil ich glaube
ich muss jetzt auch nicht sehr gänzen
ich stimme mehr zu wir haben ja die
problemebeschreibung da nur Fakt ist
auch Deutschland hat heute mit den
höchsten Wohlstand in der Welt das
höchste pro kopfeinkommen
indem man sich auf die Stärken
fokussiert und wir müssen uns doch auch
fragen was macht uns denn so erfolgreich
und es sind für mich drei große Elemente
einmal jetzt wenn Sie überrascht sein
gute staatliche Institution wir haben
starken Rechtsstaat
Bürokratie ist nichts was Institutionen
schaffen das ist häufig fehlender
politische Wille das zu verändern das
zweite die Struktur der Unternehmen wir
haben viele mittelständische Unternehmen
die nicht kurzfristig denken sondern
langfristig das macht uns unglaublich
resilient
und letzten 70 Jahren war meine Ansicht
nach die größte Stärke das Thema
Solidarität die soziale Marktwirtschaft
wo alle Menschen mitgenommen wurden und
sich darauf zu fokussieren wir haben
genug Herausforderung letzten 80 Jahren
gehabt mit der Wiedervereinigung nach
dem Zweiten Weltkrieg und jedes Mal
wieder stärker zurückgekommen und nicht
nur zu sagen was ist falsch wo sind die
Probleme sondern auch zu sagen wo sind
eigentlich unsere Stärken wieso hat
Deutschland diesen großen Wohlstand und
da vielleicht noch einen Punkt zu
ergänzen jetzt bin ich auch wieder
kritisch auch mit der Stärke meine
größte Sorge ist heute das Thema
Solidarität und sozial Akzeptanz wir
haben eben über
Energiekosten gesprochen gerade für
Menschen mit geringen Einkommen wie
besonders stark belastet werden das
Klima Geld wurde von der Bundesregierung
versprochen also man den hebten
CO2-Preis hat versprochen dass an die
Menschen zurückzugeben tut das nicht
also ich glaube die Zukunft ob wir diese
Transformation schaffen hängt
entscheidend davon ab ob die Menschen
die soziale Akzeptanz dafür da ist und
nochmals ich glaube wir sollten nicht
nur die negativen Punkte sehen sondern
eben auch die merken und dann glaube ich
kann man auch mit einem vorsichtigen
Optimismus in die Zukunft schauen
und zwar ist es ja so dass wir immer
über die Subventionen reden wenn es
darum geht große Firmen zu attraktieren
aber es ist ja so dass da ganz viel
Vorarbeit geleistet wird das ist in
Schleswig-Holstein so und das ist zum
Beispiel auch im Osten so gewesen es
gibt da große Cluster wo man dann zum
Beispiel die chip-fabriken ansiedelt wo
natürlich die das Fachkräftepotenzial
gestärkt wurde natürlich
Forschungsinstitutionen sind die dann
auch diese Menschen hervorbringen wo
auch Infrastrukturen ausgebaut werden
damit man attraktiver Standort ist und
ich glaube da muss man auch dran denken
dass man den Menschen Mut gibt an den
Standort die Potenziale haben
tatsächlich diese Potenziale zu stärken
und strukturellen dafür zu sorgen dass
attraktiv ist sich da anzusiedeln und
dann kann es sein dass hier und da
natürlich politisch auch über
Subventionen geredet wird aber ohne
diese Maßnahmen findet auch keinen
Investor unsere Standorte interessant
ich glaube ganz wichtig aber wir haben
ja da im Osten gerade ein ganz anderes
Problem da ist die AFD bei 30 Prozent
und ich komme auf das Klima Geld noch
mal zurück Frau Huberts und auf das
Versprechen der Koalition und dieses
Bundeskanzlers das ist zum Ausgleich der
Preissteigerungen in der Energie ein
Klima Geld geben wird ein wichtiges
Stichwort was ich ohnehin angesprochen
hätte weil ausgerechnet gestern der
Bundeskanzler dazu sagt wir hätten kein
Geld mehr da fehlen noch 20 Milliarden
die für die EEG-Umlage Senkung
ausgegeben wurden und man kann dieses
Klima Geld nicht finanzieren das ist den
Bürgern versprochen worden ist es
Wahlkampfhilfe für die AFD wenn man
jetzt sagt wissen wir nicht wie das
finanzieren nein ich glaube mit der AFD
ist ein ganz anderes Problem und da
möchte ich auf den Punkt Mut zukommen
also was macht uns gerade Mut in
schwierigen Zeiten wir sind
krisengebeutelt und mir macht Mut wenn
ich mir die gründungslandschaft und die
Unternehmen anschaue wo wir schon wieder
vorne sind Sunfire Elektrolyse einfach
mal um ein Beispiel zu nennen auch in
Dresden ansässig das ist so eine
Maschine die zum Beispiel den
Wasserstoff herstellt und weiß nicht ob
jeder das brauchen wir noch ein paar
mehr ich glaube
wenn wir das was wir entscheiden und das
auch wo wir hinwollen wenn wir das
geräuschloser und vielleicht auch mit
ein bisschen mehr Euphorie kommunizieren
und durchdringen würden dann wäre schon
mal viel geholfen aber was die AFD
natürlich auch macht ist die bringen ja
keine Lösungen sie polarisieren sie
gehen in die Konfrontation sie nutzen ja
auch z.B den Bundestag um für Social
Media irgendwelche tollen Videos dann
auch zu Hause produzieren die machen
einfach Angst und die Menschen brauchen
ist Perspektive die Ampel hat jetzt eine
Anerkenntnis stand heute Umfrage
deutschlandweit von
19%. das heißt 81% der Deutschen sind
mit der Arbeit dieser Bundesregierung
nicht zufrieden
da noch mal die Frage wenn sie wenn
diese Bundesregierung etwas versprochen
hat nämlich die Menschen die es
besonders brauchen mit einem Klima Geld
zu entschädigen dafür dass sie höre
Gelder bezahlen müssen höhere Preise
bezahlen müssen und gestern ein
Bundeskanzler sagt können wir übrigens
noch nicht finanzieren was glauben sie
macht das mit den Leuten
sie erwarten da eine Antwort dass wir
den Klimaschutz auch mit der
Finanzierbarkeit zusammendenken und
deswegen muss dieses Klima Geld kommen
ob das jetzt nächstes Jahr ist oder
übernächstes Jahr es hängt ja auch so
ein bisschen an der Auszahlung Steuer-ID
wie ist das Miteinander verletzbar aber
dass wir ein Klima Geld brauchen ist
ganz klar denn wir wollen die Menschen
auch nicht mit den steigenden Preisen
alleine lassen das wäre jetzt zu sagen
der Markt richtet schon nein das ist
nicht unsere Antwort als
Sozialdemokratie ich würde nicht wissen
ob Frau Grimm jetzt nicht sagt okay aber
sie haben für die energieintensive
Industrie haben sie diese 30 Milliarden
naja wenn das Klima Geld funktioniert
dann ist es ja so dass der CO2-Preis den
wir alle demnächst Zahlen in den Klima
und Transformation dann einzahlt und
dann die die besonders oft in Urlaub
fliegen oder besonders teure Autos
fahren die Zahl natürlich CO2-Preis und
das wird ja dann wiederum ausgezahlt
also da müssen wir gar nicht so viel
wenn es mal läuft noch dazu geben aber
es hängt auch sehr stark noch an der
Umsetzung und deswegen gilt es auch
beides jetzt noch mal schnell zu prüfen
weil das Klima Geld brauchen wir damit
es auch bei den Menschen an aber man
darf das Geld eben dann nicht ausgeben
für andere für Subventionen z.B und ich
glaube das ist auch ganz wichtig beim
Klima Geld dass diese Erzählung
funktioniert dass man über die
CO2-Preise etwas zahlt und zwar
wohlhabende und hohe Einkommensgruppen
deutlich mehr weil die einfachen höheren
CO2 Fußabdruck haben und wenn dann nur
jeder pro Kopf was zurück bekommt und
das wäre eben besonders unbürokratisch
dann müsste man nicht groß aus
differenzieren sondern jeder pro Kopf
dann würden eben die unteren ein
Lieblingsgruppen davon profitieren im
Schnitt und das wäre eine wichtige
Erzählung weil man dann den Leuten klar
machen könnte wir wollen die Anreize in
die richtige Richtung setzen das ist im
Grunde ist unangenehm teuer aber wir
zahlen das zurück und am Ende haben
diejenigen die ohnehin wenig haben und
die ohnehin auch wenig CO2-Fußabdruck
haben und wenig CO2 verursachen die
haben eben das war eigentlich auch die
Idee das wäre die wichtige Erzählung die
man den Leuten auch klar machen müsste
damit man eben klar machen kann die
klimatransformation wird nicht auf dem
Rücken der unteren Einkommensgruppen
ausgetragen die ohnehin schon mit den
Verhältnissen zu können ist auch wichtig
zu sagen ich glaube dadurch ist die AFD
auch so stark geworden ist manche
Probleme deutlich für die Bürger
verschlimmert worden sind nehmen wir
dieses dieser Größe heizungsgesetz viele
Menschen machen sich einfach Sorgen wie
sie noch ihre Miete bezahlen sollen oder
wie Sie die Dämmung von Häusern bezahlen
sollen und dadurch wird natürlich die
AFD deutlich stärker deutlich besser
wäre heizungsgesetz komplett abschaffen
und den Emissionshandel vorziehen auf
2025 in Deutschland dann kann sich
nämlich dezentral über
marktwirtschaftliche Lösungen die beste
Innovation am preisgünstigsten für die
Menschen eben auch durchsetzen und das
in Verbindung mit dem klimagergeld was
den Bürgern ursprünglich mal die Idee
dass man mit der CO2 kaufen dann müssen
wir den Leuten ja schon helfen da haben
wir jetzt eine Förderung bis zu 70%,
weil der Markt jetzt richtet bedeutet
dann dass man die Heizung nicht mal eben
mit 300 € im Jahr austauschen kann
überhaupt nicht so so teuer ist der
erwiesen durch Zahlen des
klimaministeriums das über das
heizungsgesetz die CO2 Vermeidungskosten
um 300 % teurer sind also wenn man das
über den emissionshandelmarkt
beschafflich Regeln würde das sind
natürlich enorm Kosten sowohl für die
Bürger als auch für die Unternehmen
darüber haben wir hier in der Sendung
tatsächlich schon sehr viel geredet weil
14 Monate wurden wir durch die Ampel
unterhalten und dann ist man im 12 Monat
endlich auf die Idee gekommen eine
regionale wärmeplanung davorzuschalten
auch das Parlament hat die Regierung da
noch mal an erinnert es geht auch anders
aber so ginge es auch genau so und jetzt
sind wir trotzdem noch mal bei der Frage
ob und wie sehr und darauf wollte ich
unbedingt zurückkommen wir eigentlich
mit den Investitionen die nicht der
Staat sondern andere Firmen private
Wirtschaft in Deutschland tätigen ob wir
nicht auch da einen beklagenswerten
Zustand erreicht haben und das gucken
wir uns schnell noch mal an
Deutschland ist wieder Weltmeister beim
Abfluss von Direktinvestitionen gut 11
Milliarden Dollar kamen 2022 rein aber
knapp 143 Milliarden flossen ab
der Saldo von -131 Milliarden Dollar
macht Deutschland zum Spitzenreiter beim
Abfluss von Unternehmenskapital und wenn
Infineon oder Intel in Dresden oder
Magdeburg investieren dann nur wenn
Staat und Steuerzahler tief in die
Tasche greifen und subventionieren
wir haben nur die Möglichkeit zu
entscheiden ob wir dieses globale Spiel
mitspielen das wird es teuer ja oder wir
scheiden aus aus dem Wettrennen das kann
auch nicht das Ziel der Veranstaltung
sein bei der globalen Subventionitis
kann Deutschland mit seinem
bürokratischen Antragswesen nur kleckern
Joe Biden klotzt mit 370 Milliarden
Dollar einfach und schnell und blockt
auch deutsche Unternehmen in die USA
so danach haben wir jetzt schon und
darauf hatten wir schon hingewiesen Frau
Grimm diese Frage noch mal Investitionen
gehen gerade massiv raus aus Deutschland
mal unabhängig davon welche Sorgen eben
die energieintensive Industrie und
andere Bereiche ja auch haben was ist
das für ein dramatisches Zeichen ja bei
den ausländischen Direktinvestitionen
muss man jetzt glaube ich erstmal gucken
es hat sich ja vieles getan wir haben
auch geopolitische Veränderungen den wir
gerecht werden müssen man versucht man
versucht sich
unabhängiger zu machen von China man hat
einen Rückgang natürlich in der
corona-pandemie gesehen der
ausländischen Direktinvestition es wird
sich wenn sich Dinge ändern in welche
dieser Länder genau aber das sind
natürlich Entwicklungen die jetzt nach
mehreren Krisenjahren angelaufen sind
und vor dem Hintergrund einer gewissen
Verunsicherung also ich glaube da muss
man auf die Daten gucken ist richtig die
Daten für Deutschland sind relativ
schlecht sowohl
Investitionen die nach Deutschland
kommen als auch
der deutsche Standorte haben
muss man sich da muss man sich die Daten
angucken und sich angucken wie die
verschiedenen Entwicklungen
zusammenspielen Diversifizierung wird
eine Rolle spielen neue Märkte wird eine
Rolle spielen kritische Rohstoffe werden
viel wichtiger da sind wir übrigens
nicht gut dabei kritische Rohstoffe in
Südamerika das merkurabkommen hängt
immer noch sozusagen wird nicht
ratifiziert und auch deutsche
Unternehmen sind nicht sehr stark
engagiert bei kritischen Rohstoffen die
jetzt wo jetzt Südamerika Argentinien
zum Beispiel setzen
dynamisch werden das ist schon ein
großes Problem ich würde aber denken
dass wir noch auch abwarten müssen wie
sich diese Entwicklung auf jeden Fall
dran bleiben auf jeden Fall dranbleiben
dass diese Investitionen nicht auch noch
das Land verlassen oder sagen Sie da
auch Herr fratcher das ist egal und es
ist auch nicht so schlimm wenn von den
energieintensiven da irgendwie die
Firmen gehen das wäre auch nicht so
schlimm es hilft Ihnen vielleicht ich
widerspreche die kapitalausflüsse haben
wir seit Jahrzehnten sie sind das
Spiegelbild der Exportstärke wir reden
über Diversifikation das Unternehmen im
Ausland investieren um sich einzige
aufzustellen Teilhabe am Wachstum von
China USA haben also diese Ausflüsse
sind etwas total positiv das Problem
sind die zu geringen Investitionen
deutsche Unternehmen in Deutschland das
ist das Problem das deutsche Unternehmen
sich diversifizieren also diese
Ausflüsse das ist etwas durch und durch
gutes es sind keine schlechten Zahlen
viel lieber in Deutschland investieren
manche tun es ja nehmen Sie die großen
Automobilhersteller mit 20 extrem
erfolgreiche Jahre hatten die haben seit
den Anfang letzten Jahr 2000er Jahre in
Deutschland kaum Arbeitsplätze
aufgeschaut die haben zum Teil im
Ausland ihre Arbeitsplätze verdoppelt
und das macht ja auch die Arbeitskräfte
in Deutschland produktiver also wir
wollen gute Arbeitsplätze in Deutschland
halten und dafür müssen Unternehmen sich
global aufstellen dort produzieren wo
sie es am günstigsten können Vorleistung
beziehen deshalb ist das die große
Stärke Deutschlands dass wir wirklich
global aufgestellt sind wir wachsen
schwächer demokratische Probleme unsere
Stärke ist Teilhabe am Wachstum in den
schnell wachsenden Volkswirtschaften zu
haben deshalb sind diese Investitionen
im Ausland etwas Gutes nochmals das
Problem sind das deutsche Unternehmen zu
wenig in Deutschland investieren ganz
unabhängig von den Investitionen im
Ausland würden es gerne und wir machen
eine schnelle Runde wenn dieser Ort hier
Meseberg wäre was würden Sie auf den
Zettel schreiben was als erstes
passieren muss damit Deutschlands
Wirtschaft wieder wächst wer möchte
anfangen Frau Hubert sagt sie haben
schon alles aufgeschrieben nein
Investition Bürokratie achso
Entschuldigung dann würde ich sagen
investitionsagenda
investitionsergender hier in Deutschland
richtig okay also genau das was als
letztes angesprochen wurde Energie
massiv ausbauen und energieintensive
Energieträger aus dem Ausland geschaffen
da wirklich Märkte hochlaufen lassen
dass wir die günstig zur Verfügung haben
so schnell selber produzieren nicht
angestrengt hier zu Versuch
in die Sendung schon einstiegen Herr
fratzsche sozial Akzeptanz die Menschen
mitnehmen und in Menschen investieren
okay Frau Ostermann wir brauchen
Angebotspolitik wir brauchen einen
wettbewerbsfähigen Standort wo
Investoren aus Überzeugungen mit Mut
gerne hier investieren weil die Kosten
günstig sind wir ein gutes
Bildungssystem haben und genügend
Fachkräfte wenig Bürokratie das brauchen
wir damit Unternehmertum
müsste ich genauso intervenieren und
sagen wenn sie eins auswählen müssen
ausdrückt gerade am meisten stört uns
Unternehmer die massive Bürokratie die
muss schnellstens gesenkt werden Klaus
Ruhe Matzen jetzt ist ja viel gesagt
deswegen kann ich ja was weiteres
ergänzen ich würde sagen arbeit muss
sich lohnen ich glaube wir haben einen
massives Problem das sehr viele Menschen
eine Arbeit nachgehen und sich fragen ob
sich das noch lohnt dass manche zu Hause
bleiben auch manchen die noch leisten
könnten das heißt alle müssen Teil der
Lösung sein und das vielleicht dann
letzte kleine Anekdote als ich in
Dänemark ich habe meinen
Abitur fertig hatte bin ich zum
Arbeitsagentur gegangen muss man sich
arbeitslos melden und dann sag ja liebe
Klaus möchtest du Europaletten bauen
oder den Strand zaubern dann bekommst du
auch eine Leistung und ich glaube genau
da müssen wir hinkommen dass jeder der
es kann muss was leisten wenn er was
haben möchte und das glaube ich ist wenn
wir wieder einen Ruck in Deutschland
haben wollen dann müssen wir verstehen
jeder muss seinen Teil bei tragen jeder
muss ein Teil der Lösung sein dann wird
es uns auch gelingen Deutschland wieder
zum sportlichen hat sich der Klaus
damals entschieden
eine dritte Variante und es gab eine
dritte Variante ich habe 3000 Kronen das
sind 400 € bekommen um nach Deutschland
zu fahren und nicht zu bewerben und sie
haben diese 400 € haben am Ende dazu
geführt dass ich hier sitzen ich glaube
das ist doch ein ganz gutes Invest
gewesen vielleicht nicht für den
dänischen Staaten aber für den deutschen
vielleicht könnte ja Urlaub 400 €
überweisen an der Dänemark und damit das
ausgleichen wird und wir haben gleich
noch gesagt es wäre schön wenn die
Menschen die hier sind und arbeiten
wollen tatsächlich auch was tun ich
glaube das auch das ist ein Standard nur
ganz kurz wir haben keine Lokführer wer
in Serbien werden mehr Lokführer
ausgebildet als sie dort gebrauchen
können wir sagen aber hier die müssen
aber Deutsch sprechen ich bin noch nie
nach vorne im Zug gelaufen habe an die
Fenster da geklopft weil ich mit dem
Lokführer reden wollte also wieso ist
das so wichtig dass der deutsch spricht
wichtig ist dass er ein lokführen kann
und genau diese Standards müssen wir
durchsprechen
werden
akzeptieren wir Berufsausbildungen aus
anderen Ländern damit wir endlich mal
hierher bekommen
da muss ich jetzt dringenden Punkt
setzen und mich ganz schnell ganz
herzlich bedanken bei diesen Gästen
heute Abend haben sie herzlichen